[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
dynamiser la formation continue des
enseignants
près de la moitié des enseignants
Français considèrent qui n'existent pas
de formation appropriées à leurs besoins
contre 24% en Angleterre ou 19% en
Belgique
dans son rapport intitulé réveiller la
formation continue des enseignants
Gérard Longuet rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances constate que la
formation continue dans le secteur de
l'enseignement et déconnecté et
insuffisantes mais quelle souffre
également d'un déficit de visibilité et
de lisibilité
elle cristallise un certain nombre de
critiques structurelles relevant moins
d'un problème de moyens financiers que
de qualité de gestion et de pilotage de
la formation observe le rapporteur
spécial
en vue de la faire évoluer en profondeur
Gérard Longuet forme une offre
recommandation à destination du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
articulée autour du triptyque clarifié
évalué valoriser en matière de budget le
rapporteur spécial veut apporter une
solution à la sous-consommation des
crédits ouverts au titre de la formation
des enseignants bien que les montants
consacrés à la formation des enseignants
initiales comme continu s'élève en loi
de finances à plus d'un milliard d'euros
les financements dédiés à la formation
continue reste mal connue faute de
système d'information qui permettent une
réelle traçabilité budgétaire
pour savoir exactement combien d'argent
est utilisé pour la formation continue
et comment il est utilisé Gérard Longuet
propose de développer un outil
informatique permettant de disposer de
manière transparente au niveau national
d'un suivi budgétaire fin et d'une base
de données dynamiques sur les formations
suivies par les enseignants
parallèlement le rapporteur spécial
préconise de faire de la formation
continue un véritable levier de gestion
des ressources humaines du ministère il
plaide ainsi pour une valorisation de la
formation continue dans l'évolution de
carrière
il recommande en ce sens de renforcer le
dispositif d'évaluation de la formation
continue et d’établir un suivi
postérieur à la formation il estime en
outre qu'il convient de tenir compte
dans la mobilité géographique des
enseignants du suivi de formation
spécifique en renforçant la place des
formations diplômantes et certifiantes
le rapporteur spécial entend aussi
valorisé le suivi de formation en cours
de carrière en conditionnant l'accès à
certains postes spécifiques
d'enseignement à la validation de
formation
enfin le sénateur souligne l'intérêt de
développer les formations d'initiatives
locales en veillant en même temps à une
inscription des actions de formation
continue au sein du projet
d'établissement
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]